so let me start with congratulations on
the movie uh i'm sure it's a very tough
day doing press today very tough
man it's always good it's always good to
see you man you know what i mean
you know what i mean though like uh but
anyway um so i got a ton ton of things
to talk to you about okay um throw in
some curveballs at the beginning if
someone has never seen anything that
you've done
um what do you want them to watch first
i mean i don't know that is a good
question you know i i don't know i mean
listen i uh
i mean i i don't know i i think maybe i
sort of know where you're kind of going
with this because i know this one's
different you know i i i think
i i think for me i i'm i'm so
like
i'm just so proud of this film i'm so
proud of being a part of it i'm so proud
of everybody
in it
and
i i'm so proud of the way that this
movie was made it was just really you
felt like it was something
uh
special and righteous and familial and
and
and and full of grace uh all all the way
through and and um
you know i i i really uh i i you know it
sounds so uh i'm just so grateful that
i'm a part of it so i guess the answer
is i want them to see this not for me
not just for for for will or engineer or
demi or you know just for the film for
what for for for what this movie means
for what it stands for um you know this
sort of like meditation of the uh on the
power of family um i just
i think we all need to see it and and
i'm i'm really i'm really proud and
grateful i get to be a part of it
if i'm not mistaken uh did i meet your
dog last time we spoke i don't remember
probably i mean i have a bunch of dogs
but oh dude oh there we go see him in
there yeah that's man yeah we're in
baltimore right now shooting so he's
yeah he's sleeping he's you know he's
working hard ready
100
um you have been known i've heard that
you can go and i don't know how method
you actually go but i've heard you can
go pretty intense into a role um i'm
curious how what's like the deepest
you've gone where someone maybe pulled
you aside and said you can you can pull
it back like a touch
you know has that ever happened
you know i think you know there was an
incident i think years ago i i i i
you know years ago when i was young
there was an incident where you know i
was playing a
police officer and i i saw a
a a woman uh somebody stole a purse off
of a a woman and i actually chased the
guy down and claimed to be a police
officer and got the purse back uh that
was a crazy story and i think i told
myself while i was you know holding the
guy waiting for the real police to come
that i had gone too far um but but you
know i think i think that word has been
so sort of like kind of misconstrued and
and misunderstood i i mean look i i
think you know again we i think you and
i have talked about this before you know
what we do
you know all these wonderful artists and
wonderful technicians uh um you know get
together on a film you know before
during and after principal photography
uh to try to make to try to craft just
these few seconds between action and cut
and try to make them the most raw the
most alive the most electric the most
honest they can possibly be so you know
i think that we have a duty
you know to to
really honor those seconds and and and
for me i think sometimes it is quite
difficult to just sort of turn that on
and and and so this idea i i don't know
that method acting means staying in
character i think that that's what
people sort of assume that it means um
but but in that i i think sometimes it
is very important
you know to really have really good
control
um and over sort of your proximity
towards the time that you're going to be
spending those sacred seconds between
action and cut but you know i look you
know for this film
you know doing extensive extensive you
know tennis training and and dialect
work and research um
you know if if that's method acting you
know like you know learning how to play
tennis and actually training people in
tennis and and and working with tennis
players working with tennis coaches i
want to be a method actor all day you
know i i think
you know understanding sort of
the the the trade of the the character
you play but then also trying to kind of
like dive into the heart and to the
emotionality um
uh it's all kind of part of the deal i
think what made this one so special is
that there was something alive and
electric and real that was going on
inside on this set
um
among everybody among the entire cast
and crew where everybody sort of stayed
in it um because i think it was a really
wonderful place to be again
this word family it just i think it
exudes it it's it's the it it's the kind
of direct array is it's the kind of man
will is um
everybody everybody's families were
present you know it was it was just it's
the only word that i think just thing
keeps coming up over and over again when
i think of this film it's just family
and and uh it was it was just that set
was a beautiful wonderful place to be
and i think it shows in the film
totally a hundred percent uh will is
obviously a very talented actor and he
is fantastic in this movie um i am
curious because i know that he stayed
with that voice and sort of in character
in between takes and he you know he
really he he really went for it in this
movie and it shows what is it like for
you it like did you guys ever go to
lunch together and you're maintaining
that accent he's maintaining his accent
you're almost in character while getting
food absolutely i mean all the time you
know it was great to kind of you know
when you have a partner to do that with
i i mean you know it's it's wonderful
and and it was really we're just trying
to make each other laugh and i don't
think we even consciously are like wink
wink hey let's just stay sort of in
character here it's just that's how we
sort of spoke to each other and we were
constantly trying you know playing games
and really trying to make
you know make the girls laugh you know i
mean coming out of my trailer
you know with my short shorts and my
hair and my mustache you know making you
you know if those
it i if those young ladies were laughing
at me i knew sort of that we were in the
right pocket so i just wanted to keep it
i didn't care whether they were laughing
at me or with me i just wanted to kind
of keep them laughing and i think the
same was sort of true with with will and
i and and really it was um
you know it was sort of seamless you
know the the the transition between
you know action and cut and just sort of
living life and then going in we just
would sort of meet up and we our banter
would kind of begin and we would just
sort of take it take it forward and and
and um you know it
when you have sort of a a collective
group kind of participating in that kind
of ensemble acting again it's it's
really the way i love to work and you
know that it it's not a it's not a
pronounced conscious decision it's just
how everybody's sort of going about it
and that's how it was there and and
again it's um it's it's just really a
credit to the ensemble as a whole the
atmosphere that ray created
100 um this story if someone had written
a script of this story they would be
like thrown out of the room because it's
so far-fetched and so unbelievable when
you were researching everything about
this story um what were some of the
things that you read that you're like
this can't be true that's not true oh
wait that's actually true
look i i i think the entire idea of
i i think the entire idea of of sort of
saying hey this is what is going to
happen this is all part of my plan
saying that plan
uh uh uh um
uh
willing that
willing that plan to come true
um
is is is such a beautiful
um
it's such a beautiful i think sort of uh
a a sort of meditation i think on
parenthood um um and and doing it in a
way that i
it's not that i'm telling you this has
to be i'm not telling you that i want
this to be i'm not telling you that i
need it to be i'm just telling you this
is what's going to come come about and
um and and this is how special you are
and and and it's not about you know
arriving anywhere it's not about
you know one day you will be this it's
it's um
behave this way you know behave this way
carry yourself
carry yourself like the champion you are
because you are a champion and i think
it's a beautiful thing to put
you you know to sort of give to our our
our kids um look i think that the one of
the moments in the in the movie that i
just um
i you know i just think it's so
beautiful is is um
the moment with serena when you know
when when everything sort of the height
of sort of venus's you know pro debut
and and and um you know serena
you know in such a human way is is you
know is saying well what about me you
know what about me and and and you know
her dad says well you're gonna you're
not gonna just you know when wimbledon
you're gonna be the best in the world
you're gonna be the best of all time you
know and and uh
that i think that comment that i was
like there's no way that actually
happened no way that he just had it was
all part of this sort of plan and that
that that um it's such a beautiful kind
of just parenting moment uh and uh so
that i i think that's the one that i
would pick
um richard videotaped everything or had
so much video were you able to watch any
of like the raw video and did that help
you with getting ready for the role yeah
we we had a a great sort of archival
team you know sort of constantly
you know showing us stuff i i it did uh
it it definitely did um but i think also
just just with rick i mean there's
there's there's so much for me there's
there's so much stuff out there
about him and the tennis community is
pretty small and i talked to so many
players you know including serena who
who who pl who played for him and and
played at that academy and told me sort
of what that academy was like and what
these macy's were like and you know if
you just go onto his instagram you know
you you can see it's it's it's constant
gaming [ __ ] it's constant fun it's
constant you know these sayings and he
doesn't mind you know he's such a strong
fierce
uh uh uh committed competitor but he's
also doesn't mind being the butt of a
joke he doesn't mind
you know
the k it is so clear that his players
and these kids come before him there's
no
bravado there's no trying to be cool he
doesn't mind being a jester he doesn't
mind clowning for these kids um but he
also demands uh he demands positivity at
all times and uh it's it's it's really
beautiful and i think
you know playing sort of this this this
buoy uh you you know in in in the in the
sort of like river that they were on
this important buoy
uh it was what an honor and and i just
wanted i just really wanted to capture
that positivity and i think above all
else you you know some real real real
love and reverence for these young women
and for this family you know that hit
that he had
uh because i'm going to run out of time
with you soon i just want to ask you a
few other things um are you are you
still doing american gigolo is that
still on the horizon yeah so you know
i'm finishing up in in baltimore here in
the next uh
in the next couple of weeks and then
yeah we're moving on to the the series
um i think in the beginning of the year
we'll begin
and so you you you guys shot a pilot for
that or you didn't yeah we shot we shot
a pilot uh we when was it we shot a
pilot some time ago
and then you know i've i've been here in
in baltimore shooting this um hbo mini
series with ray and david simon george
oh sorry i was going to be like i'm
about to get to that because david simon
what uh with american gigolo what was it
about this material that said i want to
do this
uh look man this that that was a uh uh
a a
it's a good question you know uh
you know you know if i'm being
completely honest you know that this was
a um this was something that i kind of
went into
you know with with probably more
trepidation and hesitancy than i that
than
you know any other project that i've
sort of uh joined
you know become a part of um
you know really was david david
hollander you know he he he was a
showrunner on um
uh on ray donovan and you know he really
came to me with this script and and um i
didn't really in all honesty uh have
have had real a burning desire to sort
of tell this story i didn't really
understand
kind of why we wanted to tell this story
um but then i dug in with him and what
he promised me was you know real
collaboration and
a real deep dive and
what i found you know with working with
him and sort of examining this this this
character and examine examining kind of
um
the trauma and and the victimhood of of
this sort of masculine man uh uh
and portraying him as a victim
you know um it scared me it just it
really terrified me and uh and i thought
there's i i it started to be i am afraid
to do this it wasn't that i can't do
this or i don't want to do this i really
got in touch with the fact that it just
scared the daylights out of me and and i
i've always said in art that you know
the things that terrify you are the
things you got to run at you know full
speed and and you've got to go to that
that's where you'll grow that's where
you'll discover different parts of
yourself that's where um you know being
terrified is good in in art i think and
so um ultimately that's why i made the
decision and um you know it's uh i'm
still terrified
you know and uh and and uh i i'm i'm
glad you know i'm glad
uh i'm already out of time i'm just
gonna say that i am a huge david simon
fan and i could not be more excited for
we own the city um and we'll hopefully
talk about it once you know next year
when it's going to come out right on man
yeah i hope uh i hope you dig it man
we're we're digging in hard and and uh
hopefully you'll you'll like what we uh
what we're cooking up
david simon in baltimore i'm pretty
confident it's going to be good
right
you know um thank you so much man and
listen wish you nothing but the best all
right it's always good to see you steve
you